I shouldn't complain about this I will
complain about it but I shouldn't
because the truth is I have to take
responsibility like this this is my
fault what you're what you're seeing
here this is really my fault that's the
truth we were talking about we do some
videos around the holidays there was
some suggestion there should be some
video of me eating something that's kind
of unappealing and then I actually said
I said I said why wouldn't I have a
vegan Christmas holiday
meal it was at this moment that I knew I
messed up I I don't know why I said that
I don't know why I really I cannot tell
you why I said that it's just a
temporary psychosis or maybe not so
temporary and so that's where we are now
this is where we are this is a vegan
Christmas holiday meal it's all
vegan mashed potatoes that can't be too
bad so Mash that's mashed potatoes I
think potatoes themselves are vegan
right so that's probably not terrible
and then we've got the vegan uh fruit
cake so it kind of get progressively
worse then we have the vegan eggnog and
then this year I don't know what this I
can't even I can't even look at this
this is vegan turkey tofur this is just
horrifying I don't know oh my okay this
this smell coming from this is uh is
extremely upsetting to me it it smells a
bit like a like a like going into a
porta potty on a hot day and it looks
like it too it looks a little bit like
it like what you might see when you go
inside one all right we'll start with
the Matched potatoes these can't be that
bad I know famous last words but uh it's
just potatoes
right
[Music]
so they're actually worse than you think
they're somehow bad how are these bad
they're just potatoes how did the vegans
find a way to screw up
potatoes they're pretty bag I gu I guess
cuz they have vegan they have like vegan
butter in them and that's what ruins
it you don't need the butter just do
just we don't just take regular potatoes
and mash them up put nothing else in
them they would at least be edible this
is not
edible and I take personal offense to it
as a as an Irish as an Irish American
myself I take potatoes very seriously
and so that is uh that's a crime all
right we move to the to the vegan uh
fruit cake of course I don't you know
fruit C cake in general is pretty bad I
don't think anyone even likes fruit cake
I'm not sure
why uh I'm not sure why fruit cake is
even a thing but now we're
going to try the vegan version of
it doesn't smell terrible there a little
bit of like a poar sort of smell to it
doesn't smell edible either don't get me
wrong it doesn't smell like something
you'd eat but it doesn't smell bad like
if I just had to smell this but I didn't
have to actually consume it I wouldn't
be too upset about it
[Music]
but that was too big a
bite I don't know why it took such a big
[Music]
bite
all right actually not terrible I
mean that is pretty
[Music]
bad by by vegan standards it's not so
bad but it's also the bar this is this
is fruit cake so you go in expecting
something uh horrifying and that's what
you get okay so that that could have
been worse the the potatoes actually
worse than the fruit cake the vegans
have found a way to do that I don't know
how it's the season of giving but you've
already given enough to your internet
service provider if you haven't been
using expressvpn when you go online and
I'm not just talking about the enormous
internet bill you pay every month every
time you go online without Express VPN
your internet service provider can see
and log every single website that you
visit and yes that includes all the
sites you visit in incognito mode in
addition to overcharging you your ISP is
legally allowed to sell all of your
browsing activity to third-party
advertisers for massive profits I'm done
giving to my internet service provider I
always go online with expressvpn the app
encrypts and reroutes 100% % of my
network data through their secure
servers so my provider can't see a thing
the app couldn't be easier to use simply
fire up expressvpn on any of your
devices phone laptop whatever it is tap
one button to connect and that's it
unlike your internet service provider
expressvpn is committed to your privacy
their privacy policy has even been
audited by Third parties so you can rest
assured that your data is not being
logged by anyone you've given enough to
your internet service provider this year
so take back your internet privacy today
with the VPN rated number one by Tech R
and Mashable visit expressvpn.com Walt
and get three extra months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com
Walsh YT to learn more all right I'm
still putting off the uh the turkey so
we'll go right to the vegan eggnog I
don't know how you can make vegan you
know eggnog it's all it is is egg and
and
Burbon uh so this is eggnog without the
egg
smells like a like a
cleaning some kind of cleaning like a
dish like some kind of chemical you use
to clean your your
countertop pretty bad and it and
especially in comparison to what to what
eggnog is supposed to
be
I mean don't get me wrong it's bad it's
a it's a little closer to eggnog than I
thought it would be I'm slightly
impressed I would never drink that again
of
course
try I would like to know what's in that
then we have the main the main event
um okay oh man so this is turkey but
there's no turkey at all this is made of
tofu I don't even know what tofu is I've
never consumed tofu in my life
life so we have our vegan Christmas
turkey M did you try this no you didn't
try it
no you want to try it
[Music]
no
oh my God no I can't this is not even
food I don't know what this is this
should not be in my mouth right now and
I wish I didn't just say
[Music]
that there's no way anyone eats this on
purpose oh what
the I can't even describe
this hang
[Music]
on oh my God okay it's not
just it's not just the taste I mean The
Taste is bad but it's everything it's
the texture it's cuz it's not it's not
food like you're not you can tell when
you're eating it you're not supposed to
eat this whatever it is it's
otherworldly it's like one of one of my
aliens landed on Earth and we killed it
and ate it like it's almost it does not
have the texture is
not it's got a little bit of Styrofoam
to it oh God that is that is really
quite unpleasant that is quite
unpleasant and this is and vegans
subject themselves to this on
purpose it's no wonder they're so uh
ill-tempered and sirly all the time the
vegans if I had to eat this every day I
mean I would hate every I would hate the
world
too all
[Music]
right I'm going to go throw up
now
sh